but a lot of the trans women will take
female hormones and I'm getting it right
now to make it grow
are you also taking testosterone to
mm-hmm
I'm taking estrogen for my breasts
testosterone to build
so oh that was me
but um yeah I'm just excited you know
this is who I am you know this is me are
you happier at this point in your life
very very than you've ever been maybe
really yeah
I'm more content you know
I've been calling Hey puto hey you
know but you know
it's just who I am
this is me
does your family think of it
just supportive yeah
yeah
very very very supportive
it's a Latino family
no I'm adopted oh you're adopting two
Caucasian oh I see
and I love them you know
you know
they're great parents you know